how's it going breasts it's trying to
deep the game got updated which means
I've been here before ma ah ah I swam to
a new island almost died doctor fine but
I need your yeah god damn it where's dr.
Pratt dr. crab where are you I'm gonna
die without you I hope that [ __ ]
doesn't find me what I hear you I'm
dying
come on man we were buddies hey ah there
you are
I got ya bud you find all right outputs
what you need is a little bit of back
massage put me on your back oh that
kcals tactic I have yeah how do you like
this look but that's my butthole oops
uh-oh
oh they're together that's so cute
please don't touch my girlfriend crime
shut up shut the [ __ ] why are you so
lying anyway run oh oh
I'm not hiding or anything I'm just
smelling the [ __ ] shut up you're coming
with me
daddy all right wish island um
hula doll a doll can't get a lot of COFF
COFF a lot a bigger bottom or little or
in this one call oh god let's wait to
close you like it you like my abs yeah
you like it don't you
no I don't dr. crab yeah you like it
don't you shut up dr. crab crab calling
dr. crab dr. crab dr. crab get up now
get up now the crab crab calling up the
crab doctor crap no no he escaped every
time damn it
what is this amnesia amnesia underwater
it is actually kind of creepy oh my god
sweat sweat ah oh my god there's so many
oh they're [ __ ] eating me and [ __ ] go
go go go go go go go go go go [ __ ]
how to build a hammer
the PewDiePie tutorial you just let's
throw some [ __ ] together there you go
and you got yourself a hammer
and we grab our Heather foundation Jane
done there we go
badassery boom I call you the Hulk and
that crashed it
you cannot be serious with me right now
alright well here we are then back in
the beginning and hurry this this is how
they explode continents back in the days
so you think Christopher Columbus travel
by boat huh he was a wizard just like
everyone else Hey look at my hammer all
right it looks like we're gonna have to
spend the night but I'm so lonely I wish
I had a friend it's like the crabs wife
hello boots come over to the baby okay
okay there you are you were hiding
underneath the leaf uh no I was sister
protecting the nature with my shell if
you don't like my doctor crab you can
just say how it is now no I like you I
like you a lot
uh-huh especially when you don't murder
my children was that you want me to
murder your no don't don't murder my
children all right I'm just gonna go
away
out for a minute no one tells me what to
do hey did you murder my children aah
aah
I'm sorry dr. kramm it's it's just a
helmet see you're fine he's fine
look at it
like a candle and
we can finally an hour later go on our
motorboat
I packed Heather I packed some other
[ __ ] just go you're not you're not going
we to fight sorry Heather
oh god Heather you hello ah yay
adventure ha ha it's fine
oh man this thing goes fast damn Wow hey
Shannon are you doing yeah brah
stupid [ __ ] oh my god a stingray hey
buddy
think about the palate pull a pot oh I
will chop onto your mother and you will
be a fine carpet come on man why aren't
you a car man yeah that's right [ __ ]
it's right you were a carpet [ __ ] your
boat a carpet and your dad copy hey are
you doing I'm not so happy yeah you
don't look too happy
I'm so sad oh you can be my carpet will
that make you happy no well you're cool
though
hey stinger you can I can fly it I can i
comfort throw him like a frisbee look at
this Wow look at that amazing I hate my
life
you shall kawaii hi mr. chan come with
me I'm I vote we will have adventure no
stink you're not supposed to go away
from me sing you're doing it wrong man
all right sting that's it go on without
you
all right bros it looks like a nice tan
that episode everything George god
dammit I was gonna ride after the sunset
and moonlight [ __ ] me Johnny's video hit
that thumbs up little brother bulla
bulla thanks for watching moon as always
brofist stay awesome Marjorie
shut up inside of a [ __ ] I'll pocket
Kalia paired dude dude don't worry she's
fine it's fine